[Music]
5 25 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well while the Nevada
Department of Transportation is busy
tweaking that diverging diamond
interchange on trop over the I-15 and
starting to rebuild the destroyed North
half of the street there's a little
something something starting to happen
just to the north
it's right there at Harmon over the
freeway that's the street that gets shut
down to cars during Raiders games so
folks can walk back and forth between
the strip and the stadium well then
Dot's about to start construction there
on what's called a half freeway
interchange going to look a lot like the
one up in the far Northwest Valley on
Elkhorn at us 95.
and while they're doing that they're
going to be some overnight freeway lane
closures but the bigger story is that
that half interchange is scheduled to
open sometime this fall which will
hopefully lessen the pain of the next
complete closures of both trop and the
freeway when the South half of trop goes
bye-bye in Tropicana
2.0
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the driving
you crazy conversation at traffic eight
at eightnewsnow.com